peak performance yes that is the title  of apple's upcoming march 8th event and  mark german was right but the craziest  thing about all of this is the title  peak performance which has some major  major hints for what we should be seeing  we'll definitely get the iphone se we'll  definitely get the ipad air we might get  a new color for the iphone as well as a  lot of new spring cases for the iphone  13 potentially two desktop macs and one  macbook we think it'll for sure be an m1  pro m1 max mac mini with a new design  but then potentially either a new imac  or a new m2 mac mini as well as  potentially an m2 macbook pro and that  is why apple is calling it peak  performance